arms and the man I sing the latest
battle of Berkeley is underway as UC
students demand psychological counseling
in the lead-up to the Orthodox Jew they
call a Nazi Ben Shapiro speech at the
craziest university in the country will
discuss this year of campus chaos with
some who's been at the center of it all
Berkeley College Republican President
Bradley Devlin then Allie Stuckey Ariel
Davidson and Cassy Dillon joined the
panel of deplorable z-- to discuss some
criminal rappers stupid music video in
which he Lynch as a white boy
Swedish YouTube gazillionaire
PewDiePie's dropping the n-word and
leftist criminals vandalism of New York
City's famous Central Park statue of
Christopher Columbus I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
Shapiro Shapiro is making trouble that
notorious Jewish Nazi he is going up to
Berkeley right now I think as we speak I
imagine they're gonna call in the
National Guard
to prevent a conservative writer from
giving a speech on campus you know I am
glad that we got him on the show last
week because this they're gonna be out
for blood for this guy they're gonna try
to prevent him from giving a speech
about how bad political violence is
unbelievable almost beyond parody now
maybe the most incredible aspect of all
this is that a New York Times opinion
columnist penned an article yesterday
supporting ben shapiro can we check the
weather outside
[Music]
it is truly unbelievable very surprising
for those who haven't been following
let's go through the timeline of the
Berkeley chaos what people are calling
the Battle of Berkeley so this actually
began in the 60s Berkeley was the hotbed
of the Free Speech Movement which is
incredibly ironic because now they are
the out that of the anti speech movement
they're trying to do everything they can
to prevent anybody that they even
vaguely disagree with from giving a
speech on campus this began in February
February first the conservative
provocateur Milo yu-na police went to
give a speech at Berkeley the funny
thing about all this I have seen my
Logan appleís speak I saw him at UCLA I
wanted here we had to say I wanted to
see the circus surrounding it he doesn't
have a speech there is no speech that
it's it's he plays these people like a
fiddle a lot a lot of people on the
right do there isn't anything basically
what Milo did is he went up there he
banned heard a little bit with Dave
Rubin and then some screaming hideous
social justice warriors stood up and
Milo made fun of him for a little bit if
they had just calmed down there wouldn't
have been a speech there that when we're
talking about more mainstream
conservative thoughtful voices if they
just allowed these people to talk on the
topic so they want to talk about there
would be no chaos no one would pay
attention there wouldn't be national
headlines but they simply can't do it
what did they do when Milo Annapolis
went to speak let's take a look
[Music]
this is an event at Berkeley where my
Lily innopolis who is known as an
internet troll a self-proclaimed
internet troll a very provocative
speaker he was invited here to the
campus and you can see from the reaction
I'm gonna step out of the shot here what
is happening here is that these are
student protesters some anarchists from
what I can gather try trying to breach
the building right now they don't look
like students to me I don't know about
you but some of those guys are in their
thirties I think students this true it
depends on the university I guess maybe
at Berkeley as the students look like
it's just black clad terrorists so in
the aftermath of all this there was a
hundred thousand dollars of property
damage a Syrian Muslim was actually
attacked by a protester who said quote
you look like a Nazi who knew I
certainly didn't know that and he is so
then fast forward March 4th happens
there's a march for Trump lauren
southern was oh this was later Lauren
something's supposed to speak in April
at the March for Trump seven people were
injured April fifteenth Lauren Southern
supposed to speak and Tifa sets off
bombs and fireworks eleven people were
injured there six were hospitalized one
was stabbed then you fast forward to
April 27th Ann Coulter was supposed to
give a speech UC Berkeley canceled it
they would not let her speak they said
we'll reschedule for a time when there
are no students on campus and Coulter
gavel levan says absolutely not I'm
gonna go I'm gonna give a speech she's
not allowed in now tomorrow Shapiro
himself is heading into the thick of it
all and we can now bring on a guy who
has been at the center of all of this UC
Berkeley College Republican president
Bradley Devlin Bradley you are doing
God's work over there thanks for coming
on hey thanks you know I tell you I I
was a college Republican president not
too long ago back in the good old days
of 2012 and you know I vary from time to
time found myself at the center of the
left-wing vitriol on campus but all in
all it wasn't that bad I mean nothing
like we're seeing here certainly nothing
like we're seeing at Berkeley
how are they treating you over there oh
absolutely horrible
it started yeah it's laughable almost
because this hysteria started long
before Maya innopolis it started when I
wore my GOP shirt for the first time on
campus and I was looked at and called a
racist and a bigot by two individuals
who engaged in zero conversation move
there on election night the surprise
acquainted Donald Trump my friend got
punched in the face at a pizza parlor
for expressing excitement people were in
tears in my fraternity house as we
watched the election you're telling
about that guy's in a fraternity were in
tears that a Republican I don't I really
don't understand
left-wing men I kind of get left-wing
women because women are more nurturing
they're probably more compassionate than
we knuckle-dragging men are but you're
telling me fret frat boys were upset
that Donald Trump won well this might
shock you but he worked for closely over
the summer yeah yeah there was a men and
woman just in absolute hysteria Wow and
it escalated from there Milo came onto
campus and this radicalization that
happens in the birth the area was
bubbling up underground and he finally
came to the surface finally Milo gave
them an outlet to express their anger
and they did so with a bunch of college
students locked in the second storey
effect well you know I was it an
interesting case there I think because
he unlike Shapiro recharge Murray or an
Coulter whoever Milo specifically
doesn't seem to have very much to say
and I don't even mean that as a knock on
him he himself describes himself as a
performance artist and provocateur and
all that is there any hazard to
associating ourselves with these kind of
provocateurs and carnival barkers or do
they do they serve an important purpose
right now as the left humiliates itself
time and time again well I think Shapiro
is filling that yeah perfectly you don't
need to bring someone who is a
provocateur on amis to show the left's
own insanity Milo when he
panders to the alt-right or when banning
panders to the alright and give them
legitimate platform and the left does
this as well when they call everyone all
right up up end all right right news
month ago when they call everyone
alright it actually gives these people
more of a platform and associating
conservatism with all right and the
unabashed tribalism that follows the
alright is very very dangerous for the
conservative movement and we can't we
can't move forward and republican party
without about in Ferengi ating a lot of
these guys you know Richard Spencer and
I had James Allsop on the show and
people who are playing around with the
alright it seems to me there were none
of these people it seems to me they are
a really small minority obviously it's
bad ideas and the bad ideas should be
refuted but Hillary Clinton I think
wants to pretend that half the country
has suddenly gone Nazi do you think the
alt-right has gained ground on college
campuses or is it all a bunch of
nonsense I think that when you label
everyone else horrible to be a certain
ideology there's going to be people who
fall into the trap of oh the right
fights against the scourge of political
correctness therefore I am associated
with the outright I am an internet troll
I am a goofy kid who stays on reddit and
fortune yeah and I don't wear Brooks
Brothers but I voted for Trump so I
guess I'm on the all right is that
exactly i I can align myself with you
all right
easily because everyone labelled and
that's that's a very dangerous scenario
because when actually think individuals
who could become good constitutional
conservatives to an ideology that
associate your ethnicity whatever creed
you look like look like okay so are
these protests and by protests I mean
riots that include tear gas and fires
and things like that are they about the
speeches or are they about something
bigger who gets to control who gives a
speech or something larger it is it's
definitely about group it's about you
know a very Orwellian style of thought
that has taken over the mainstream luck
there should be no reason that Brian
Fallon please folks and
during the 2016 campaign it's a picture
of Allied soldiers invading Normandy and
say left-wing demonstrators violating
property property by having no permit
you know that these are completely
different scenarios and it's repugnant
of these individuals who are higher up
and left mainstream media mainly to not
condemn and T Fund contempt condemn this
violence outright because apparently
Antipa preaches tolerance in all of
these leftist ideology just put in a
very violent that should sleep well this
is very problem
I noticed Bradley I've looked for video
clips of you setting fires and throwing
garbage cans through windows and I
haven't found any and it makes me notice
that we as conservatives we don't
protest their speakers or even if we
protest them we don't shut them down we
don't borrow them from entering
buildings we don't create violence what
is it about the left and the right in
America right now that makes them resort
to violence to shut us up and has us
perfectly willing to let them have a
platform I think it actually can be
traced back to less ideology of creating
the state as basically your church as
your village and anyone who believes
that the state is fallible that
individual communities and individual
rights matter more than an authoritarian
state they find that as an assault on
their themselves and on their ideology
that must be combatted with violence and
me absolutely watch dissenters
essentially absolutely right that that
the fetishization of government or the
replacement of what we used to have as
the foundation of our civilization in
our society with the state it does seem
that they've become quite tribal what do
you make of this Berkeley was the
beginning of the Free Speech Movement
fsm in the 1960s now they're the
opposite of the Free Speech Movement is
there some bizarre change that's
happened or even in that free speech
movement was it similarly a bit of a
misnomer and really just a way to
advance left-wing goals such as
protesting the Vietnam War well yeah I
actually have
Shapiro's auntie fuh poster that i
wanted to show you this is meant in 1964
and in 2016 so it's a bunch of cops in
riot gear in 2016 that apparently guard
fascist amaze huh
yeah it's absolutely incredible no the
new first speech movement was yes to
establish free speech for individuals
who believe Marxist ideologies in the
sixty nonetheless
and when table nonetheless they were
able to espouse their views on college
campuses now we're worth receiving that
same pushback by a liberal
administration in the present and the
reason that we filed a lawsuit against
the University of California Berkeley
the young America's Foundation and
coordination with Berkeley College
Republicans is that they're they have
created policies that they apply to
restrict conservative ideologies
speeches on campus this is a violation
of the process of our constitutional
rights of free speech and equal
protection under the law these are
incredibly problematic you are thinking
about it in the long term what if in the
future it's the liberals who are
suppressed by a conservative of our
court that's what I always bring up to
the liberal students you ask me why are
you suing the school why are you
creating this litigation that's gonna
waste taxpayer dollars and I always have
to report with well what if you're in
this scenario what if you were locked in
a second-story of a ballroom with m80
fireworks being thrown at you what if
your friends were assaulted David and
really all we have I'm sorry go ahead
they always they always nod their head
they reciprocate and they usually sign
up for a mailing list are we are one of
the biggest political organizations on
campus we have over fourteen thousand
individuals sorry interested but only a
hundred Fillmore meetings and that's
what the left has done they've made
conservatives incredibly take well
that's better than us Yale I think we
had about eleven members we were the
most written about ten percent Club on
campus but that is a really good work
that you're doing Bradley so I
appreciate it stay safe out there don't
give those left-wing thugs an inch
tomorrow and keep up the good work
you're doing a great job thank you very
much Michael now it is time to bring on
our all-female panel of deplorable z--
Bradley he's a good-looking guy he
he cleans up well but we got to get him
out of here so we can have an all-female
panel of deplorable 'he's excited today
to introduce ariel davidson from the
Hoover Institution
we have Cassie Dylan and we have the
blazes Allie Stuckey ladies thank you
for coming on thanks for having me
we'll begin with the most important news
out of YouTube a vicious criminal rapper
named xxx tentation just released a
music video if one can call it that
comparing the killing of Michael Brown
himself a criminal who reached for an
officer's gun to the killing of Emmett
Till an innocent 14 year old boy who was
lynched in 1955 the video shows the
rapper placing a noose around a little
white kids neck ostensibly to make some
sort of point
xxx tenth a.cian himself was arrested
last October for false imprisonment
witness tampering and aggravated battery
of a pregnant victim his arrest report
reads quote defendant punched and kicked
victim victims both eyes were punched to
where both eyes became shut and victim
could not see a hoodie and sunglasses
were put on the victim in order to get
her out of the apartment complex
avoiding anyone seeing her victim
escaped from new location and contacted
the nearest Police Department
all of that is background on this video
do we have a copy of the video
[Music]
[Music]
just like the Brandenburg Concerto isn't
it
Ariel this criminal possesses no musical
talent and he beats up pregnant women
why does this video have 5 and a half
million views already well my first
guess would be that this is something
that sort of feeds into the identity
politics intersection of sort of crazy
radical production of media so I'm
thinking is a longer sentence and I
intended but basically I'm thinking of
like Kathy Griffin desk type a cry for
attention so whenever you produce media
that's extremely controversial or
violent or at all sort of makes people
wince you're immediately gonna get the
viewership that you're looking for so if
you're someone that's incredibly
untalented this might be a wonderful
tactic in order to get people to pay
attention to you I think that you know
someone like Kathy Griffin whose career
was sliding down the tube it was great
for her to hold up a head of Trump in
order to garner more attention than she
might get on pure talent alone so you
know this to me just signals this
person's probably not worth my time just
because they're probably extremely
untalented and this is a way for them to
get attention it's grotesque it's
disgusting it's despicable but this is
how you know this is how at least modern
media is going about ways of you know if
they don't have talent this is how for
the advice on modern media note to self
Cassie
he is going to trial this guy xxx
whatever his name is he's going to trial
on October 5th for beating up a pregnant
woman what is a just punishment for
someone who beats up pregnant ladies
well it depends are you somebody who
believes a child and the womb is a life
or not because if it is a life and no
then you should be trying
there's all battery in two different
people honestly he's one of the probably
the worst people who are alive right now
that's completely insane like he did
that and I think you're right Ariel like
he's just trying to save his failing
career and by doing so he's also in the
same group of people that called Donald
Trump very divisive and then you could
make some video like this and just makes
it even more divisive so good for him
and I hope it this video somehow
distracts from his trial which and I'm
sure in our criminal justice system
which pays little attention to justice
I'm sure he'll be put into some
rehabilitation program or something like
that
Ali where does this terrible culture
come from CNN's Don Lemon says that
specifically among young black men from
ages 18 to 25 it's because they grew up
with that father's 72% of black babies
today are born out of wedlock now Don
Lemon is wrong about everything else so
it may as well be about this why where
is this terrible culture coming from
yeah I mean it's a little bit tough to
speculate because there's evil you know
across the races and across the
political spectrum
I think Arielle was right on point when
she said that this is just a product of
identity politics and also a product of
a lack of talent I think that
intersection explained very well why
this video exists but yes of course
anyone's background has something to do
with how they deal with certain
political or cultural circumstances he
is choosing to make a false equivalency
between two things that are not
historically parallel whatsoever I'm
just in order to get attention um
unfortunately we see this a lot on the
left of making perilous for example
comparing illegal immigrants to slaves
saying that it's the exact same thing
and that we should legalize them in the
same way it's not the same at all but if
you complete two ideas no me the
emotional response that it's going to
get then you you trick people into
thinking that they are being successful
social justice warriors simply by
telling history incorrectly and that's
what he's choosing to do unfortunately
it might be just as effective as he
wants it to be apparently it is we're
talking about it
and we want to talk about a lot more
things but unfortunately for you dear
viewer you have to go to daily wire comm
right now if you want to see the rest of
the show we're gonna have to say goodbye
to Facebook in YouTube but thank you for
everybody who's already subscribing you
help keep the lights on here and if you
go to daily wire comm right now it costs
ten dollars a month 100 dollars a year
you get me you get the Andrew Clavin
show you get the Ben Shapiro show
assuming he stays safe up Flay up at
Berkeley but forget all of that none of
that matters when you consider the
leftist tears tumblr oh my gosh it is a
thing of glory it is the finest vessel
it's going to be overflowing after
tomorrow's speech at Berkeley it will
keep your leftist tears hot or cold
always salty and delicious so go to the
Daily wire comm right now and we will be
right back
[Music]
[Music]
speaking of race relations Swedish
YouTube superstar PewDiePie is in
trouble for saying the n-word on one of
his videos here is his apology it was
something that I said in the heat of the
moment I said the worst word I could
possibly think of and it just sort of
slipped out and I'm not gonna make any
excuses to why it did because there are
no excuses for it I'm disappointed in
myself because it seems like I've
learned nothing from all these past
controversies Arielle similar question
to what we just asked Ali but in a
totally different cultural sphere this
guy became famous for making videos of
himself playing video games which seems
like the most boring thing ever
why does PewDiePie have over 57 million
subscribers well I think you know I had
to do a bit of research on him myself
I've heard of him but I was curious why
he has he does have almost 60 million
subscribers people love watching his
videos and it's not just about video
games see someone that delivers hiding
commentary he talks about the news of
the day he actually did a segment on the
gender wage gap so this is you know a
person that is it's about video games
maybe at the kernel but there's more to
it beyond that so he's somebody that
sort of tapped into the younger
generations thirst for content and he
produces it at a rapid pace I mean every
day his day consists of producing this
content um you know I applaud him for
going on there and being very open with
his viewership and apologizing I believe
the apology video had almost 6 million
views so good for him for doing that I
think you know it was necessary to do
that he's been sort of embroiled in past
conflicts and at least involving like
Nazi slurs of some kind I'm not really
sure what else he's been involved in but
I do apply those ones I guess right yeah
he's been involved in some other ones as
well but I like I said I do applaud him
for going on and being very open with
his viewers and saying you know I
screwed up and I'm
incredibly sorry he has a major
influence in terms of how large his
viewership is its global and again he's
tapping into the Millennials thirst for
content and YouTube is has you know it's
given him a tremendous amount of fame
and it's also given him an incredible
income to I mean he's earning tens of
millions dollars a year doing this gig
and he was originally a hot dog so I
actually didn't know that that is this
guy makes over ten million dollars a
year that means that really makes me
rethink my life choices even even blank
book included that we don't make that
kind of money on blank books Ali
is it ever appropriate for a white guy
to use that word as an insult or even in
common speech oh absolutely not
um however I will say that the conflicts
and kind of the chaos that we have found
PewDiePie embroiled in and fat I've been
following him for a while and I really
like him I don't even like video games
but I will say that the chaos that we've
kind of seen him in the midst of in the
past has been reporters that have gone
after him because they don't like the
fact I think that he one is not
outwardly liberal or doesn't fit into
their narrative and two has made tens of
million dollar of dollars off of not
being an expert in anything
I think journalists don't like I've only
made tens of dollars out of not being an
expert he's doing something right
traditional media and traditional
journalists don't like these kinds of
people that have such big influence and
didn't do things the right way and don't
say things the right way so do I think
that what he said was wrong absolutely
but I do want to take it with a grain of
salt because last time they went after
him from a random obscure reference that
he had already denounced of Nazis that
wasn't even really a reference to Nazis
and this time yes it was pretty explicit
he shouldn't have said it but I mean
there's conversations about taking down
his videos and D monetizing what he's
doing and making sure that video games
don't partner with him anymore and to
the last conversation that we just had
of that horrible rap
and everything he was saying are we
seeing the same kind of pushback there I
don't know no it seems like a double
standard to me should he have said it no
but should he be demonetised and
stripped of his influence because of
that No
Cassie is this a question of political
correctness or is this just simply about
manners and politeness I think this is
about manners and politeness in this
case I think what he said was wrong I
think there's no need for him to say
that I think he was playing video games
and just said maybe forgot that he was
taking a video of himself and said
something that he shouldn't have said
but I do think that he is kind of like
an edgier person so that makes the media
watch him very closely and I think here
we should just let the free market play
and just let people who disagree with
what he said
it's unfollow him I was subscribed
that's what's gonna alternate Lee get
rid of his mass wealth and he's getting
from playing games on YouTube I guess
even if he loses everything now he could
retire like two or three times over so
good on the guy good on him for
apologizing apparently left-wing
criminals have vandalized New York
City's famous Central Park statue of
Christopher Columbus after Mayor Bill
DeBlasio the Bolshevik on Bowery
suggested the city might include it in a
list of offensive statues set for
removal how do we fight these bullies
who are going to take what they want
democracy or rule of law be damned Ariel
how are we going to fight them that's a
big question well I think we you know we
we appeal to the people who realize or
maybe haven't spoken out yet about how
sort of craziness is I think there are
plenty of people on the left side of the
spectrum who think that this sort of
crusade against the statues is absurd I
think that there are plenty of people in
the center who would agree with that
so my you know my best tactic at least
in conversation has been to take the
leftist logic to its logical conclusion
and so I say okay great let's let's say
we'll get rid of any semblance of
Christopher Columbus will take away
Columbus Day as a holiday we should
probably get rid of
on the circle every singles will ban
meatball hoagies mm-hmm right well get
rid of the District of Columbia who
should probably rename that to um and
then let's go further Kyle Smith and
National Review had a great point he he
pointed out the District Columbia but he
also said something about how the Duke
of York James a second was very heavily
involved in the slave trade okay so we
have to rename the stay in New York we
should probably start off with the city
as well so you start to see how this
kind of cascades into an arranger
emeritus Buchi after whom America is
named he was an Italian and I don't know
if you've studied what the Italians did
to Carthage but it's absolutely
despicable and we have to rename the
continent - absolutely
my point being here is that you know
American history is not it's a beautiful
thing but it's also a very bloody thing
and we have a lot of times in our
history where we've done horrible things
and I say we as a collective you know
nation historically in the past not we
us personally but we have to be very
careful about when we we go about
destroying any semblance of American
history because we're attempting to
erase it um and for better for worse
those things did happen and there were
some really horrible things that
happened but getting rid of statues it's
not necessarily about it nobody ever
talks about the good thing it's the
crysta there they always talk about the
worst they don't talk about the better
the things that came from Christopher
Columbus this issue bothers me so much
because it's so ungrateful and
historically ignorant without
Christopher Columbus without that guy's
courage none of us would be here today
without that guy's courage and his
gumption to get Spain to pay the tab for
his trip a very Italian thing to do to
get the other guy to pay for it without
that America which has been the greatest
national force for good in the history
of the world for ourselves and for
everyone else on earth would not exist
we owe it to that man Ally where does
this culture of willful ignorance and
ingratitude come from is it endemic to
our times right now or are conservatives
blowing it out of proportion is it sort
of always this way is there nothing new
here I think social media actually plays
a really
card in all of its just creating the
ideological echo chambers that we have
and not being able to separate facts
from feeling I mean that's pretty much
what Twitter is it's just an entire feed
of how people feel and unfortunately
that's where the majority of people get
their information and I think that has a
lot to do with it with a lazy populace
that would rather believe what they
already feel and kind of feed into their
own preconceived notions of how they
think the world works rather than be
brushed up against or inconvenienced by
facts and research and because that kind
of emotional rhetoric is so easily
available to us via social media and the
ease even is created by an algorithm to
only feed us the things that we already
think and feel unfortunately people have
to go out of their way to understand
what is true what is not and to be
challenged in their preconceived notions
and I think people just don't want to do
that when it's so easy to believe what
you want that's so true the hysteria
that comes from being constantly fed
your own opinions Facebook will not feed
me everyday feminism articles which is
my favorite website on the Internet
but it won't feed them because it thinks
that I disagree with what must be a
conservative satire site Cassie where
does it end
it was president Trump correct will this
end with us knocking down the Washington
Monument I think we need to find a
middle ground so if people want to
remove statues from their own local
community that's fine as long as they're
going through the process to remove it
asking the City Council talking to
whoever's the board of trustees of the
park or rubber whoever this statue is
but going in vandalizing a statue in a
public place is wrong it's a crime it's
criminal and it shouldn't happen I think
that like you said earlier we'd have to
rename a lot of things I think what we
should do instead is call out the people
in history who have done bad things but
also talk about the good things I've
done too because everybody has done good
and bad and we should look at both sides
other than Hitler I mean I don't know if
Hitler did them any good I guess he was
an OK painter painter but your point is
absolutely well taken we've swung so far
in this other direction that all you
ever hear about is what a bad guy
Christopher Columbus was
this howard zinn form of american
history where everything we ever did is
terrible and you don't focus on the
greatest force for national good in the
history of the entire world okay ladies
thank you for being here especially you
Ariel David Center your first time also
Ally's Stuckey and Cassie Dylan can't
wait to have you back and now it is time
for the final thought the left-wing
violence erupting on college campuses
has nothing to do with what conservative
speakers have to say it has everything
to do with who controls what they and
therefore you are allowed to say there
is no alt left there's just the left
which has followed it's bankrupt ideas
to their logical conclusions and now
bereft of the civilized argument that
defines human society and the reason
that defines humanity itself is left
only to grunt and scream like the
animals that their destructive ideas
have made them become Chesterton wrote
there is a thought that stops thought
and that is the only thought that ought
to be stopped let's wish Ben good luck
in his speech and hope that the thought
that stops thought doesn't stop him
first
I'm Michael Knowles is the mic on all
show come back tomorrow get your mailbag
questions in we'll do it all again
[Music]
[Music]